President Trump does a presser with
Vladimir Putin in the world goes insane
Democrats cried treason and we
deconstruct some culture I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
so first off let me remind you that if
you haven't heard already this August I
am taking the Ben Shapiro show live to
audiences in Dallas and Phoenix you'll
be able to see me in person and join in
an audience Q&A tickets are going fast
visit daily wired.com slash events to
get your seats and additional info or
basically sold out in Dallas go check it
out really quickly if you want to get
those seats daily we're calm / events
also I want to remind you that China has
now announced fifty billion dollars in
tariffs to counter America's fifty
billion dollars in tariffs across
thirteen hundred products at categories
all of this can cause serious price
inflation a hedge against inflation and
a hedge against uncertainty and
instability can be precious metals gold
is a safe haven against uncertainty
which is why my savings plan is
diversified I don't mean take all your
money and stick it in gold I mean take
some of your money and stick it in
precious metals because that's what I do
the company I trust with precious metals
purchases is Birch gold group and right
now thanks to a little-known IRS tax law
you can even move your IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver it's perfect for people who
want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from future
geopolitical uncertainty and when you
look back historically what you see is
that gold is never worth nothing when
the bottom falls out of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard your savings
Birch gold has thousands of satisfied
customers five star reviews A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau you all
know about their free information kit
for a limited time qualified purchases
can earn up to an additional 10 grand in
precious metals for free through July
31st to find out if your purchase
qualifies contact Birch gold right now
go to birchgold.com slash pen again
speak to a Birch gold rep mention I say
it's birchgold.com slash been and the
offer only runs until July 31st terms
and conditions to apply ask your sales
representative for details go check it
out okay
so president Trump did a press
conference with Vladimir Putin yesterday
it was bad it was not a good press
conference the President of the United
States essentially sided with Vladimir
Putin over his own intelligence agencies
who lest we forget work for him hey
these are the people who work for him if
he doesn't like how the Intel agencies
are doing their job he can replace their
leadership which he has already done
with the FBI
yeah he has his own CIA head in there
the dude has all of the people he wants
in place so if he doesn't like his own
Intel agencies and what they're telling
him he has every capacity to find new
more honest intelligence agencies he's
not actually doing that which suggests
that he knows full well that the idea
that the Russians were attempting to
interfere in the election is true now
does that mean that the Russians
actually swung the election to trump no
doesn't mean that
from colluded with the Russians no but
the problem for President Trump is that
he is personally so egotistical that he
believes that any in any sort of a spur
any aspersion that is cast at the
presidential election of 2016
must be false because he believes that
he won fair and square and that means
that anybody any anything anybody says
about what went wrong in 2016 with the
Russians all of that is an attempt
merely to undermine his grand victory
and therefore anyone who claims that the
Russians were attempting to hack into
the election system basically all those
people are simply unwilling to accept
that Hilary lost listen I'm willing to
accept that Hilary lost and it is also
true that the Russians were attempting
to monkey with our elect our electoral
system and they're attempting to monkey
with our with our so election cycle with
the news cycle by hacking into the DNC
the DCCC and the Hillary Clinton
campaign while all of this manifested
itself in a pretty awful way yesterday
when President Trump got up to the
podium with Vladimir Putin a lot of
people soft-pedaling this today a lot of
people on the right particularly
suggesting that this wasn't a big deal
and none of it really matters yesterday
I said I'm not sure that it matters a
lot in terms of Vladimir Putin invading
other countries I'm not sure that it
matters a lot in terms of actual
hard-headed foreign policy but it does
matter in terms of the American
perception of our own intelligence
agencies and it matters with regards to
Vladimir Putin's perception that he can
play with Trump when it comes to
monkeying with our news cycle and
hacking into enemies of President Trump
President Trump did a real disservice
yesterday what he did was was really
rather unprecedented in modern American
history I don't mean completely
unprecedented because you do have Barack
Obama who sent pallets of cash to the
Iranian mullahs you do have Barack Obama
who pledged flexibility on a hot mic to
the Russian government but to go before
the entire world and suggest that your
own intelligence agencies are wrong and
a thug piece of human debris like
Vladimir Putin is right when he lies
about how he didn't hack into the DCCC
or the DNC or Hillary Clinton's campaign
when you do that you are doing a real
disservice to the American intelligence
agencies as well as to America in
general you can't do that well president
Trump did do it so Trump had this
presser with Vladimir Putin and he
starts off by saying our relationship
has never been worse but he solved it
our relationship has never been worse
than it is now
however that changed
as of about four hours ago okay well if
you really believe that four hours ago
the the change happened then you're in
the same category as george w bush who
said he looked into Vladimir Putin's
eyes and saw his soul or Barack Obama
who sent Hillary Clinton to bring a
reset button that was miss marked it
said something else on the button that
that's the same category so that in and
of itself it's foolish but it's not
particularly damaging then we get to the
damaging stuff so president Trump is
asked about the the sort of decline in
the relationship between Russia and the
United States and he did something that
if it came from the lips of Barack Obama
would have been perfectly predictable he
said everyone is to blame particularly
the United States I hold both countries
responsible I think that the United
States has been foolish I think we've
all been foolish we should I had this
dialogue a long time ago a long time
frankly before I got to office I think
we're all to blame and nobody signed up
for this when President Trump says
America first when he says make America
great again
it doesn't mean blame America first
America is not responsible in the
decline of the relationship with Russia
Vladimir Putin invaded two sovereign
states in the last ten years two of them
and the United States did very little
about it Vladimir Putin turned Iran into
a sphere of influence and Syria into a
sphere of influence and the United
States had very little about that now
was the United States wrong not to do
more about these things of course the
United States is wrong less to do more
about these things but that's sort of
like saying that the bus and the person
run over by the bus are equally
responsible for the accident
a pedestrian has the right-of-way the
United States is not responsible for
Vladimir Putin actually invading
surrounding countries and murdering
dissenting journalists and murdering
dissenting politicians the United States
not responsible for any of that stuff
and for Trump to suggest anything
different is Howard Zinn no I'm Chomsky
territory and then it gets worse so the
president is obviously very upset with
the Muller collusion investigation and
he has a right to be upset about that
because he says I didn't collude there's
not a lot of evidence to suggest that he
did collude at this point and so he
launches into a rant about how the probe
is a disaster for the country well the
problem is the probe is doing a couple
of things the probe is looking into the
possibility that the Trump campaign
works with Russia and Trump I think has
a right to be upset about that I think
he has a right to be upset with the idea
that the intelligence agencies has led
by people like P
struck were biased against him in their
attempt to pin Russian collusion on him
and his campaign I think has every right
to be upset about that but he does not
have a right to be upset about
intelligence agencies coming up with an
estimate that says that the Russians
hats the DNC and the DCCC and the
Hillary campaign all that is very well
verified all of our intelligence
agencies agree on that
so when Trump says that the probe is a
disaster for the country what he really
should be saying is any suggestion that
I colluded with Vladimir Putin is a
disaster for the country because it's
not true
well when he undermines the intelligence
agencies by throwing out the baby with
the bathwater he got a problem here he
is talking about the probe I think that
the the probe is a disaster for our
country there was no collusion at all
and that was a clean campaign I beat
Hillary Clinton easily there was no
collusion I didn't know the president
there was nobody to collude with there
was no collusion with the campaign okay
all of that is not great but it's not
the worst thing in the world then we get
to the actual worst quote okay the worst
quote is he says Vladimir Putin protests
and Putin says listen I have nothing to
do with this hacking he smoked me nyet
and it's not I had nothing to do with
any of this and Trump instead of saying
listen
Vladimir you and I disagree about this
my intelligence agencies came to a
different conclusion there my
intelligence agencies and I have to take
what they say at face value because
they're the ones who are doing this hard
work instead from takes his intelligence
agencies and he dumps them directly
under the bus it's really bad it's
really bad I people came to me dan
coates came to me and some others they
said they think it's Russia
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be but I really
do want to see the server but I have I
have confidence in both parties so I
have great confidence in my intelligence
people but I will tell you that
President Putin was extremely strong and
powerful in his denial today and what he
did is an incredible offer okay this is
weak-kneed stuff this is weak it looks
like Trump got unmanned by Putin here
that's what it looks like just for any
objective viewer if you're not a Trump
fan if you are a Trump fan you at least
have to try and be objective as to what
happened
today Trump look like he was bullied by
Vladimir Putin on that podium he looked
like Vladimir Putin owned him on that
podium he makes a couple of statements
that are worthy of explication in that
particular quote so first the president
says I really do want to see the server
now this goes to his suggestion that the
DNC has not turned over its servers to
the FBI because the DNC is hiding
something so the theory goes something
like this
the FBI goes to the DNC and they say
listen we think you've been hacked by
the Russians and the DNC says no we're
not going to show you anything which
would be suspicious if that had been the
case if they'd said we're not going to
show you anything because we are trying
to hide something because we actually
leaked out these documents ourselves
seth rich or something then you'd be
suspicious but that's not actually what
happened okay let me give you the facts
on the DNC server because there's a lot
of fiction that's going around today and
I think that fostering that fiction is
not useful so the theory on the right
seems to be by some on the right and
Sean Hannity talked about it last night
on his show I think Sean is wrong
basically the theory on the right is
that show that the DNC is hiding
something so they didn't turn over their
servers to the FBI but the FBI somehow
came to the conclusion it was the
Russians anyway and here's what Trump
said yesterday said you have groups that
are wondering why the FBI never took the
server haven't they taken the server why
was the FBI told to leave the office of
the DNC I've been wondering that I've
been asking that for months and months
I've been tweeting it out calling it out
on social media where is the server I
want to know where is the server and
what is the server saying okay so here
is the real story about the server okay
a server is a physical entity you do not
have to grab a physical entity that has
on it computer materials and bring it
outside the offices of the DNC in order
to examine those materials in the same
way that you can remotely access your
computer from home the FBI has the
capacity to remotely access the material
on those servers The Daily Beast has a
pretty good look at this today and say
when cyber investigators respond to an
incident they capture the evidence in a
process called imaging they make an
exact byte for byte copy of the hard
drives they do the same for the machines
memory they capture evidence that would
otherwise be lost at the next reboot and
they monitor and store the traffic
passing through the victims network this
has been standard procedure and computer
intrusion investigations for decades the
images not the computers Hardware
provide the evidence both the DNC and
the security from CrowdStrike hired were
to respond to the breach have said
repeatedly over the years they gave the
FBI a copy of all the DNC images back in
2016 so the DNC didn't
have to turn over its physical servers
because they were still using those
during the campaign the FBI had access
to the imaging via CrowdStrike
and via the DNC James Comey said as much
in his testimony he said he wanted to
rekt access to the DNC servers for
purposes of accessing their live Network
and this is what the DNC turned the FBI
down now is that suspicious apparently
it's not all that uncommon according to
The Daily Beast when the computers
belong to a cooperating victim seizing
the machines is a pretty much out of the
question said James Harris a former FBI
cybercrime agent who worked on a 2009
breach at Google that's been linked to
the Chinese government in most cases you
don't even ask you just assume they're
gonna make forensic copies said Harris
now vice president of engineering at PFP
cyber like we have a computer company
here we have an Internet company
if the FBI wanted to investigate what we
would allow them to do is image all the
material we wouldn't allow them to take
all the servers out of our office we
couldn't do our work then so this isn't
anything nefarious per se the DNC was
not covering for a leak of material to
the Russians and a bunch of people say
what CrowdStrike crowd strikes a
democratic firm well not really
CrowdStrike is also used by the RNC so I
think it's important to get rid of
misinformation because it prevents
clarity okay I want everything that we
believe to be based at least on a
certain number of facts now in just
second I wanna get to Vladimir Putin's
response to all of this first I wanna
say thanks to our sponsors over at Peter
Millar so these folks make the best
clothing I mean this is just top of the
line Club this polo shirt that I'm
wearing right now this magnificent polo
shirt that is Peter Millar it's Comfort
it's fit its quality and its style
they're setting the standard in menswear
recently a proceeding with style tips
from the clothing guides at Peter Millar
if you are somebody who likes to golf or
somebody just likes to dress like you
like to golf well that's what Peter
Millar is about Peter Millar is about
quality and value and style it's the
most comfortable clothing that I've worn
I mean this this shirt is supremely
supremely comfortable right now I'm
wearing their performance polo you can
get that as well
again these polo shirts are really
comfortable they're really stylish I
also have their five pocket pants which
are excellent I have a pair of shorts
that I wear every weekend from Peter
Melara time I take my kids to Disneyland
am wearing the Peter Millar shorts the
performance polo I'm wearing right now
is supremely comfortable and so is all
their other clothing and it looks great
right now head over to Peter Millar comm
slash Ben and check out some of my Peter
Millar favorites and be sure to use my
link you'll receive complimentary
shipping as well as a free hat that's
Peter Millar mi ll AR comm slash Ben
Peter Moeller comm slash man one of the
reasons you want to use peter Millar is
because you don't need one thousand
pieces of clothing you just need a few
pieces of really nice clothing and
Peter Millar can do for you check it out
Peter Maillard comm slash Ben other
stuff is supremely comfortable as well
as stylish it's pretty awesome Peter
Millar comm slash Ben and you can get
complimentary shipping and a free hat as
well okay so Vladimir Putin responds to
President Trump and you can see he looks
like the the cat that just ate the
canary I mean you look it's he is so
gleeful he is so happy about all of this
here is Putin a dictatorial thug who
murders dissidents talking about how you
know there's there's no reason why
President Trump
shouldn't believe me I mean he's such a
weasel here's that you can hear the
translator here here's what Putin had to
say as to who is to be believed that
who's not to be believed you can trust
no one if you take this could you name a
single fact that would definitively
prove the collusion just like with
president okay you have to see the body
language I mean Putin is so comfortable
he's so happy up there I love that line
as to who is to be believed and who's
not to be believed you can trust no one
okay spoken like a former KGB agent and
then he was asked specifically if he
wanted Trump to win the election and
here's what he had to say isn't it
natural to be sympathetic towards a
person who is willing to restore the
relationship with our country who wants
to work with us now do I really think
that Vladimir Putin was attempting to
rig the election for Donald Trump in any
serious way no I believe the the
intelligence community's assessments
that he was attempting to mess with the
election in order to create chaos and
guess what he just created a lot more
chaos yesterday because now half the
country believes that Donald Trump is in
the pocket of Vladimir Putin now I don't
think Donald Trump is in the pocket of
Vladimir Putin I think that Donald Trump
is an egomaniac who likes being
complimented who likes having his
shoulders massaged Putin massages his
shoulders and Muller doesn't so he
doesn't like Muller he does like Putin I
think it really is almost that simple
and Putin knows this which is why he
says of course I was trying to trump
elected he knows what kind of chaos
that's gonna cause at home he knows that
that causes gridlock and anger in the
American political system that his
Putin's goal so what that requires is
for people on the right to recognize
that Trump needs to put his ego behind
him and recognized who Putin is will
talk about who Putin is in just a second
and at the same time folks on the Left
have to understand that every time they
scream collusion to the sky without any
evidence
every time they suggest that we are in
crisis mode or that Trump has committed
some act of treason all they are doing
is giving Putin what he wants in a
certain sense which is a certain level
of chaos in the American political
system okay so how about a guy's Putin
so Putin was on with Chris Wallace and
Chris Wallace at Fox and his really
grilled Putin he started off by asking
Putin about NATO and Putin essentially
said that NATO should never expand
because NATO is a threat to Russia there
is an opportunity for bilateral contacts
with the Member States which was done
people left Poland with Romania which
now station and deploy elements of the
strategic anti-missile defense of the
United States moving this NATO
infrastructure towards our borders would
be a threat and the reaction would be
extremely negative okay and then Putin
follows that up he's asked specifically
about whether they have compromised on
Trump right this is the theory from the
left is the reason Trump is doing all
this is because Putin has the P tape or
some such nonsense and Putin says no I
don't have any compromise now can you
trust Putin saying he doesn't have any
compromise of course not the guy's a KGB
spy like why in the world would you
trust for a demur Putin that said he
does say that he doesn't have any
compromising material on Trump though if
he did would you expect him to announce
it on Fox News that would be great right
in the middle of the interview they say
do you have compromised from is of
course I have tape of trumping Piton by
russian prostitute but that that's not
that's not gonna happen there anyway
here here is him talking about with
chris wallace whether we have something
on them we don't have anything on them
and there can be anything on them
I don't wanna insult President Trump
when I say this and I may come come as
rude but before he announced that he
will run for presidency he was of no
interest for us okay my favorite part of
this interview is the part where Chris
Wallace tries to handle Admiral put in
the indictment right this indictment put
out by the the Moller investigation of
these 12 Russians and Putin refuses to
look at his utter ly ridiculous just
utterly ridiculous and this is the guy
that Trump says he believes as much as
the intelligence agencies do you really
believe that someone acting from the
Russian territory could have influenced
the United States and influenced the
choice of millions of American
I'm asking whether they tried ok and and
Putin refuses to answer that question
look how clever Putin is there right so
Chris Wallace asks him did you try to
influence the election Putin says we
never could have influenced the election
if we influenced election then Trump
would move so we never to influence the
election well he's playing to an
audience of one there in the audience
he's playing to is president replica the
worst part of this interview and also
the best part is the power of Putin has
specifically asked about him murdering
his political opponents his answer here
is such a Bond villain answer and you
just see that the camera slowly pulls
back and Vladimir Putin is petting a
hairless cat it's really unbelievable
here is Vladimir Putin being asked
whether he murders his political
opponents well having presidents been
killed in the United States have you
forgotten about it
well has Kennedy been killed in Russia
or in the United States which is still
up now please forget mr. King what
what happens to the clashes between
police and civil society and some
several ethnic groups spectacular stuff
from Vladimir Putin right there so do
you kill your political opponents well
can we kill the new mounted states
Luther King killed United States right
they were assassinated by criminals
you're the government of Russia
I'd make fun of Vladimir Putin more
except that I know that he kills people
so I'm a little bit I'll be honest with
you it's a I'm gonna I'm gonna steer
clear of that one because I'm fond of
breathing but this is the guy who Trump
decided that he wanted to favor in these
in these negotiations this is the guy
that Trump wanted to compliment and pat
on the head during these negotiations if
you had watched that press conference
with the sound off well you would've
assumes that Putin was the powerhouse in
the room and Trump was the weak link
okay we have the same sort of phenomenon
when Obama was president he always felt
like the weakest guy in the room
well Trump that's supposed to be the
opposite of what he is right he's the
brash bold rude American who goes in
there knocks heads together he's the guy
who goes into NATO and tells the Germans
they better pay up he's the guy who goes
up to Canada and tells Justin Trudeau
that he looks stupid with that hair
right that's that's the guy who the
American people elected they didn't
elect the guy who goes in there and then
talks about how Vladimir Putin is really
a nice guy when you got to know him and
have Vladimir Putin's assessment of the
2016 election is more accurate than that
of his own intelligence agencies now
what's the practical impacts of any of
this does Putin actually believe that
Trump is
such a weakling that he can now walk
into Lithuania or Latvia or Estonia he
can walk into the Baltic States and he
can just take him over and the trumple
do nothing about I don't think that's
what he thinks
but I think that Putin is just really
happy that the United States seems
embroiled in this chaos that he has
helped create and that is exacerbated
everyday by the dual problem of trumps
ego and the left's brutal and ridiculous
attempt to paint Trump as a Russian
collude ur right those are two sides of
the same coin and both of them are
pleasing Trump are pleasing Vladimir
Putin infinitely they're really really
pleasing Vladimir Putin now speaking of
all of that in just a second I want to
get to a new indictment brought by
Robert brought by the the Muller
investigation by robert muller and but
first i want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at Omak so you've already
heard about omega-3s you know that omega
threes are one of the healthiest things
that you can do for your body over 75
percent of Americans don't get enough
Omega threes in their diet you're
probably one of them so here's why
they're important to your health and
they can improve focus and memory they
can boost cardiovascular health they can
alleviate joint pain many of the top
sellers on the market though don't
contain enough Omega threes to give you
actual results and this is why you need
to head over and go you need to need to
head over to try Oh max calm slash
Shapiro and get a box of Oh max three
for free that's try Oh max calm slash
capiro for a free box of Oh max three
ultra pure now one of the cool things
that that Oh max three ultra pure does
they're 94% pure omega-3 fatty acids
they have this thing called the freezer
test challenge so basically if you take
any other omega-3 in you stick it in the
freezer when you take it out it's gonna
be cloudy because it's not pure omega-3s
but when you take their Oh max soft gel
and you put it in the freezer when it
comes out it actually remains clear
because it is that pure it is clinically
tested so it's safe for you and your
family and because it's pure and because
it's potent that means that you're not
going to have the the fish burp and fish
flavor go check it out Oh max three
comes with a 60-day money-back guarantee
you have plenty of time to try it and
feel that Oh max difference go to try Oh
max calm slash capiro today get a box of
Oh max three ultra pure for free that's
try Oh max calm slash capiro to get your
free box of Oh max three T ry om a XCOM
slash a pair of terms and conditions to
apply get that box of Oh max three ultra
pure for free when you go to try Oh max
calm slash appear oh okay so meanwhile
Robert Muller has brought a new
indictment the person charged in this
indictment is a lady named Maria boo
Tina she's 29
and she is basically this redheaded
supposed gun rights activist who spent
an awful lot of time since
2013 going to Republican functions and
ingratiating herself with pro-gun rights
people and then she was using those
pro-gun rights people to get to
politicians I should say I want you to
fix me up with congressman Dana
Rohrabacher for example and somebody the
gun rights organization would say well
this seems like a nice pro-gun rights
lady from Russia
I'll fix trumpets Dana Rohrabacher and
then she would go and try and create a
back-channel between those Congress
people and members of the Russian
government this is what the indictment
basically says so according to law and
crime the woman who the Department of
Justice has charged for allegedly
failing to properly register as a
Russian operative well in the United
States apparently bragged several times
she helped the campaign of President
from communicate with the Russian
government maria booty no 29 was charged
saturday the complaint was not unsealed
until monday july 16th boo Tina's
alleged bragging about the Trump
campaign connections was reported in
February 2017 by The Daily Beast the
original report is now getting renewed
attention due to the criminal complaint
The Daily Beast report says she was in
business with the Republican activist
Paul Erickson and previously worked with
Alexander tortion a member of Vladimir
Putin's political party who once served
as a Russian senator before becoming a
leader of the Central Bank of Russia
so Paul Erickson it should be said is a
very active member of sort of upper
ranking Republican circles now Paul
Erickson Hobnobs with a lot of prominent
Republicans I've met Paul Erickson at
like a David Horowitz Freedom Center
event and always seemed like a nice guy
apparently he had formed some sort of
company with this marina Maria boo Tina
but there are no allegations that he
actually violated the law so the big
question is whether people who are
fixing up boo Tina with actual members
of the American government knew she was
a Russian agent and whether the people
in the American government knew she was
a Russian agent and even if they did
know she was a Russian agent there's
nothing wrong with a back-channel so
long as no actual illegal activity took
place they're a bunch of holes that
still have to be filled in the left
however is jumping to the conclusion
that booty nough is the go-between
between Trump and the Russian government
and that she is the Nexus of all
collusion those charges are not in this
indictment so this is people jumping to
conclusions in a pretty significant way
boo Tina reportedly bragged about the
Trump campaign twice
once during a November 12 2016 birthday
party said to have been attended by
Ericsson and Trump campaign aides at a
cafe near American University in
Washington DC she brazenly claimed she
didn't part of the Trump campaigns
communication with Russia two
individuals who were present said
according to The Daily Beast however dr.
Svetlana Sovran skya who's a professor
at American University said that booty
no made the same claim in class the
second time she
about the alleged connection supposedly
she tried to broker a meeting between
Trump and Putin in 2016 okay that
doesn't necessarily mean an election
collusion they could have met for any
reason you know presidential candidates
meet with a lot of foreign powers that
doesn't necessarily mean that they are
colluding with those foreign powers to
change the effects of an election people
however are jumping to the most
ridiculous conclusions about all of this
my favorite is this political reporter
today who tweeted out this morning a
picture from the Oval Office a picture
of President Trump moving to shake hands
with Sergey Lavrov who's the Foreign
Minister of Russia as well as ambassador
sort of get his lyac and then in the
very very background there's a redhead
there's a redhead in the background so
this woman is kind of a pretty redhead
and Emily singer who reports from mic
tweeted out I thought this was a
Photoshop but it's not this is Maria
blue tina arrested for being a Russian
spy in the Oval Office with Trump hey
thousands and thousands and thousands of
retweets only one problem it's not that
lady it was Carrie it was Carrie luck
khun's from the National Security
Council and then she deleted the tweet
so you know people jumping to
conclusions trying to paint Trump as a
Russian collaborator when in reality
Trump is just an ego an egotist driven
by that ego to say silly things from
time to time and say dangerous things
from time to time again one of the big
problems I see here is that because
President Trump is so invested in
countering the narrative that the
election was monkeyed with it's led him
down a path of defending some pretty bad
people so here's President Trump
defending poem Anna for poem anna fort
has been under investigation by American
intelligence agencies for years and they
have a lot of goods on him but here's
Trump defending Manta for it when really
what he should be doing is saying I
didn't know anything about mana for when
I hired him I was told by the RNC that
he'd be a good guy to hire so I hired
him and then he turned out not to be a
good guy and I fired him okay all of
which is accurate manna fort was walking
around the Republican halls of power for
years and years and years and years he's
closely associate with Elia Brody the
former finance chair of the Republican
Party he had connections the highest
level of the Republican Party all Trump
has to say here is I didn't know much
about Manta fort I hired him and then I
fired him when something went wrong
instead he now finds himself defending
Paul Manta fort because he wants to
rebut any accusation that the Russians
had any part in the election so now he's
become a press agent for the Russians
which is why is Trump doing this like
why how is this productive in any way
with Paul Manafort who's who really is a
nice man you look at what's going on
with him
it's like Al Capone well I mean it sort
of is like Al Capone in the sense that
manna for broke the law so there's that
and then President Trump was on with
Sean Hannity last night and I can tell
you this there are a lot of folks in the
White House who were not supremely happy
with the President of the United States
his comments yesterday and they were
dreading the fact that Trump was going
to go on with Sean Hannity not because
they disliked Sean they loved Sean
but simply because they knew that sean
has a tendency to double down on every
worst excess that Trump has and that's
what happened on national TV last night
Trump bragged to Hannity about Putin
denying the Russian meddling why exactly
why is this good for Trump
why if you want to help president
Trump's administration why is this good
one week ago
one week eight days ago the presidents
of the United States nominated Brett
Kavanaugh for the Supreme Court and I
was pretty happy about that so where the
vast majority of Republicans it was a
winning moment for president Trump a
couple of weeks ago the President of the
United States was on the upswing and now
the President of the United States had a
very bad two weeks and I think he had
the second worst day of his presidency
yesterday after charlottesville and yet
he was on national TV doubling down on
all of this doubling down on it why
because he and when you have an echo
chamber he tend to double down on the
things you believe whereas if you were
to open your ears a little bit you might
recognize that two things can be true
ones one Trump did not collude with
Russia - Russia did attempt to influence
the election both of these things are
true the left can't accept that Trump
didn't collude and Trump can't accept
that Russia interfered is a heroes Trump
defending Vladimir Putin on sean hannity
show last night I hate this so much I
can't even tell you I think it's a huge
mistake by President Trump and I think
that it's driving a lot of Americans to
believe things that are just not true
and I am more committed to the truth
than I am to a political agenda the
truth is that the Russians as an
American the Russians attempting to
interfere in our election is a bad thing
it was bad when the Russians attempted
to interfere by providing President
Obama more flexibility in 2012 and it is
bad that the Russians were attempting to
hack all of these various democratic
sources during the election cycle but
here is Trump defending Putin - Hannity
first of all he said there was no
collusion whatsoever
I guess he said as strongly as you can
say it they have no information on Trump
we get questions on the witch-hunt and I
don't think the people out in the in the
country
buy it but the reporters like to give it
a shot I thought that President Putin
is very very strong okay what is this
very very strong nonce and says the same
thing about kim jeong-hoon of course
he's strong he's a dictator but he's a
dictator of a third-rate country hey
Russia as a nation has the same GDP as
Italy and we're treating Russia as
though it's some sort of grand world
power that Trump has to cope with on the
on the world stage in the weakest
possible way I saw it judge Jeanine came
out today and she said what do you think
trunk what would you expect Trump to do
go out there and shoot Putin I didn't
realize that the users were the two
options shooting Putin in the face or
surrendering to him publicly I didn't
realize these were the two options I
thought there was a whole range of
options between those two by the way if
from headshot Putin in the face I think
even Putin would have appreciated the
manliness of that or if Trump had
actually just gone up there and shot
Putin on Fifth Avenue I think that Putin
probably would have said more power to
you mr. president at least you have the
balls to do it but instead what we got
was president Trump acting very foolish
it now with all that said there are two
sides to the coin when it comes to the
the promulgation of a nasty politics in
the country what Trump did yesterday is
inexcusable mm in in a different way
just as bad is the Democratic
overreaction and the reason I say that
is because when you have people claiming
treason instead of this is stupid
this is a problem it's really terrible
when you have people claiming treason or
making claims that the Russians would be
happy that you're making that's not
helpful either
I'll talk about that in just second
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daily wire calm and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire when you do you get the
rest of this show live you get the rest
of the other clayvin show live the rest
of Michael moles of show live plus
Andrew Cleveland's conversation is
happening today at 5:30 p.m. Eastern
2:30 p.m. Pacific so you can ask drew
any of the questions you want when you
are a subscriber you can watch anywhere
but you can only ask him questions if
you do subscribe so I asked him why he
does his hair that way go check it out
over at Daley wire.com also the annual
subscription is $99 as opposed to $9.99
a month a little quick mental math will
tell you that is $20 cheaper than the
monthly subscription on an annualized
basis to check out that you get the
leftist tiers hundred Club tumbler when
you get the annual subscription the most
popular tumbler in all of America so go
check that out as well but also make
sure you subscribe at YouTube make sure
you subscribe to iTunes values however
some day specials that come out you're
not gonna see those unless you're a
subscriber and we have some really good
stuff coming up I believe is Erica
Weinstein this this Sunday and we have a
bunch of huge guests coming up in future
weeks as well so go check that out
we're the largest fastest grow
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so the reaction to president Trump's
press conference the Putin should be
twofold one it should be people saying
that was really inappropriate the
President of the United States should
never be dumping his own intelligence
services under the bus for a KGB agent
and number two let's look at the
practical ramifications what he did
so doesn't mean the Putin's going to
invade surrounding countries probably
not doesn't mean that Vladimir Putin is
going to get more aggressive on the
world stage maybe maybe not although
last time he got aggressive on the world
stage we bombed Syria doesn't mean that
the intelligence agencies are gonna feel
a lot more unjustified Heat yes doesn't
mean that there's gonna be more
political dissension in the United
States yes was it good no okay that I
think is a relatively objective take on
what is going to come out from all of
this because President Trump operates
pretty independently of his own
administration his own administration
when it comes time to make policy
actually goes and makes the policy and
Trump says a lot of stuff I've been
saying it for literally years literally
years that his slogan shouldn't be make
America great again it should be I say a
lot of stuff because Trump says a lot of
stuff okay and that means that a lot of
people don't take the stuff he says
particularly seriously I don't think
Vladimir Putin takes Trump seriously
enough on policy he's gonna go invade
surrounding countries believing the
Trump is gonna allow him to do that and
it is important to mention that in this
terrible press conference Trump did say
at least one good thing he said listen
we still have our disagreements about
Crimea so he didn't come out and say
listen Putin gets to keep Crimea he said
that the United States and Putin
disagree on Crimea so when it comes to
territorial aggression by the Russians
Trump did not signal weakness he
signaled weakness when it came to
Russian interference in American
elections and he signaled weakness
because his own egotism got in the way
of his better sense I think okay so
that's the practical take the non
practical take is a trump is a traitor
Trump is a Russian agent all of this is
because Trump is some sort of Manchurian
Candidate and yet that's exactly what
Democrats are suggesting which is what
Putin wants what Putin wants is to drive
chaos in the United States his actual
goal is to make us all hate each other
and suspicious of each other and think
that we are all foreign agents of an
evil power that that is exactly what
Vladimir Putin wants and the Democrats
are eager to jump to that because they
think they're gonna make electoral gain
off the back of that and they may be
right okay there's a generic ballot a
generic congressional ballot out
yesterday it shows Democrats are back up
to an eight point lead which is wave
territory for Republicans so Democrats
think that the the more overboard they
go on this stuff the better it is for
them electorally it may very well be but
it ain't good for the country here's
Chuck Schumer yesterday saying millions
people are gonna wonder if Putin has
dirt on Trump after Trump's behavior
millions of Americans will continue to
wonder if the only possible explanation
for this dangerous behavior is the
possibility that President Putin holds
damaging information over president
Trump okay why would you give credence
to that there's not a lot of credence to
that why wouldn't just say the obvious
again the obvious thing is that
President it's the unifying feature of
all of the silly things he's done
whether it is firing Comey precipitously
or whether it is attempting to defend
Mike Flynn or whether it's do something
to defend Paul Manafort or whether it
was what he did with Putin yesterday or
whether it's him talking about firing
rod Rosenstein right all of there's one
unifying thread Trump's ego that's the
unifying threat now the left is seeing a
unifying thread in from colluded with
Russia that is a lot more far-fetched
than Trump is an egomaniac which he has
been for legitimately his entire life
okay this is a guy who used to call the
New York Post to report on them his
amorous adventures with various starlets
and he would make things up and claim
that his name was John Miller and he was
his own PR agent that's the guy we're
talking about is it more likely that
that guy's an egotist will say stuff to
protect his ego or is it more likely
that that guy is a secret Russian agent
moving around the back channels of the
Kremlin in order to do Vladimir Putin's
dirty betting which one is more likely
which one is more likely okay any case
the left decides that it's worthy of
going nutso John Brennan who
legitimately voted for a communist party
candidate in the 1970s I'm not sure what
he's whining about he tweeted out Donald
Trump the Brennan of course the CIA
director under Barack Obama Donald
Trump's press conference performance in
Helsinki rises to and exceeds the
threshold of high crimes and
misdemeanors it was nothing short of
treasonous not only were trumps comments
in basilic he is wholly in the pocket of
Putin Republican Patriots where are you
three question marks okay so every time
you say treasonous hey there there's
such a thing as you know treasonous
behavior I get that and I get that there
is such a thing as using the word
treason colloquially you don't actually
mean that Trump should receive the death
penalty but the overwhelming use of the
word treason yesterday on the part of
the left suggests that there are some
people who really believe that not only
should Trump be removed from office but
he has committed acts of treason coming
from the same people who cheered when
Barack Obama sent blank pallets of cash
to terrorists in Iran I find all of this
more than slightly irritating but this
the wine last night Stephen Colbert did
the same thing he said that this was
this was treason this is great comedy
here from Stephen Colbert one of our one
of our great American comedians we gotta
say said egotism hold on egotist +
naivete alright times false equivalence
equals yes treason yeah it's treason so
that's treason again the double standard
when it comes to treason is is pretty
stunning right here and if people were
just using this colloquially I think
that'd be one thing I think it's also
rich coming from people who believe that
it was totally fine when Barack Obama
was pledging flexibility to the Russian
government in 2012 and I don't buy it
okay that was not the worst of it it got
even worse okay so the worst of it
actually came courtesy of some woman
named Jill wine banks I'd never heard of
her
but Jill wine banks apparently a former
Watergate prosecutor and she's on with
Ali Velshi over at MSNBC so she is
talking about how terrible this was and
she runs out of ways to call this
terrible here's what she has to say and
I would say that his performance today
will live in infamy as much as the Pearl
Harbor attack or crystal MACT and it's
really a serious issue that we need to
deal with
the Pearl Harbor attack 2400 Americans
dead crystal knocked the murder of 90
plus Jews and the beginning of the the
run-up to the Holocaust yeah it was
exactly like that when the President of
the United States had some dumb crap
about the intelligence agencies exactly
exactly the same thing it didn't stop
there okay it just it got worse and
worse over the course of the day and
it's gotten worse even today the the
left's desired to go above and beyond on
this stuff is really astonishing so
let's take for example CNN is Jim Acosta
so Jim Acosta the the left has this
bizarre this bizarre tendency to
attribute gay feelings to people that it
doesn't like so the same left that will
say not that there's anything wrong with
that that homosexuality is something
worthwhile and wonderful and if you ever
make a joke then this means you are a
dramatic homophobe will make gay jokes
about Barack Oh will make gay jokes
about donald trump on a regular basis so
here's Jim Acosta the most obnoxious
reporter over at CNN Jim Acosta loves
that dude some Jim Acosta find you
somebody who loves you like Jim Acosta
loves Jim Acosta here is Jim Acosta on
CNN yesterday explaining that it looked
like a marriage but it was unclear who
was the wife between Donald Trump and
Vladimir Putin I I don't know which side
is the bride and which sign of is the
groom Anderson but it sort of feels like
we're at a wedding here and on the other
side of the room our friends from the
Russian Federation it feels like we are
at a wedding between Donald Trump and
Vladimir Putin this is actually before
the press briefing right that's actually
before the press briefing so who's
already foreseeing that there is going
to be some sort of a consummation of the
wedding night on stage very weird to see
reporters do this sort of stuff and then
of course there was there is the New
York Daily News which of course hates
President Trump they they put out a
cover and the cover looked something
like this had opened treason right and
then it shows a picture of Donald from
shooting Uncle Sam in the head while
holding hands with Vladimir Putin is
this sort of stuff going to raise the
temperature such that there will be a
serious assassination attempt on Trump
that I got to say I don't think that
would surprise me at this point anyone
when you're when you're constant when
you spend all your days thinking that
Donald Trump is essentially Thanos and
that he's gathering Infinity stones and
he's gonna snap his fingers and
everyone's going to die or at least half
the people are going to die would it
surprise me if somebody takes a pot shot
at Trump and that the temperature has
been raised because of this that would
not surprise me in in any real way now
would that
the fault of the New York Daily News no
but what they're doing here is immoral
okay it's immoral to suggest that Trump
is shooting Uncle Sam in the head by
doing this now is what he did wrong yes
it's wrong I spent the first half hour
of the show today talking about just how
wrong this is
but to suggest that that Trump is
murdering America by attacking the
intelligence agencies I find a little
bit much and then of course there's
Trevor Noah over on Comedy Central
officially named the second done
funniest person in the world Samantha
bee of course is this is the least funny
person on planet earth here is Trevor
Noah going after President Trump using
the vulgar language to which has become
accustomed so now the formerly
purposeless meeting between Trump and
Putin had a meaning right it was time
for Trump to put his foot down and he
did right on America's dick now well
justjust classiness all the way through
and super funny because he said the word
dick right when you say that word then
that means that you are you are really
really funny is what I've come to learn
from our from our comedic masters over
at Comedy Central okay with all of this
said what's the final outcome here's the
final outcome in two weeks nobody
remembers any of those really that's the
final outcome this looks like a black
splat on Trump's resume and nothing
materializes barring some sort of
precipitous action by Putin that Trump
doesn't counter that is the actual
outcome of this how do I know this
because after charlottesville everybody
forgot about it in three weeks and it's
only been one week since we selected a
Supreme Court justice and nobody
remembers the dude's name because the
news cycle is just this fast so people
suggesting this is the end of the world
we're never going to recover no we'll
recover and we'll go on and if anything
there's a good case who made that
Trump's behavior actually increased the
perception of the intelligence agencies
around the country except with regard to
people who think that every word that
comes out of Trump's mouth is invariably
true and wonderful and that he's playing
17 degree underwater upside down Hungry
Hungry Hippos but I think the likelihood
is that most people do what you are
doing today what most people are doing
today they look at Trump saying stuff
and they say look at that dude dude says
a lot of stuff right dude says a lot of
stuff because he says a lot of stuff I'm
not going to take any particular thing
that he says on an individual level
incredibly seriously and I don't think
that's inappropriate
I think discounting what President Trump
says is something that's been done
domestically I think it's being done on
foreign policy it was done with her
garden a doe just last week you know
President Trump ripped into NATO and
there was a suggestion that Trump was
going to pull out of NATO and you know
what the NATO folks said he said yeah we
had a great meeting
NATO's doing great because they just
ignored him
and I think when it comes to what
Vladimir Putin said about the
intelligence agencies and Trump siding
with him is it a bad moment for Trump
yes does it demonstrate a lack of
character in president Trump yes
does it have any long-lasting
ramifications does it undermine the
entire presidency doesn't mean that
Trump can't get good things done anymore
no it doesn't mean any of those things
but I think it would be worthwhile for
Republicans to note when President Trump
does bad things because it is
intellectually dishonest not to do so
and also don't push president Trump to
double down on a bat even Newt Gingrich
and Laura Ingraham are on Trump over
this thing okay it's not about people
being anti Trump being all over Trump
for what he said
it's about anybody with any sense of
objectivity realizing that Barack Obama
had said the same thing we would've been
all over his ass okay and when Trump
says that kind of stuff then he deserves
the flak he gets okay time for some
things I like and then some things I
hate them we'll deconstruct the culture
in a pretty serious way so let's start
with things I like so I just read a
great compendium of sports pieces by the
columnist Gay Talese the the book is
called the silent season of a hero and
to all these old essays there's some
particularly good ones he has some
really great writing about the boxer
Floyd Patterson from the 1960s who was
eventually defeated by Muhammad Ali in
an attempted comeback he has a great
piece about Joe DiMaggio and sort of the
the waning of Joe DiMaggio in in his 50s
and he writes really well not only
doesn't write really well he was
described by Tom Wolfe as one of the
founders of sort of the new journalism
the new journalism this idea of
narrative journalism this long form
journalism where wasn't just about the
who what where when why instead it was
also about drawing characters and
writing nonfiction in a way where you
could actually feel the characters the
book is really fun and worth reading
again the silent season of Heroes sports
writing of Gay Talese who's actually
quite a good columnist interesting guy
basically CI she came out and he
suggested that he understood why Trump
won he's real New Yorker gay talese and
so I think he sees Trump is sort of a
1960s Rat Pack figure which come to
think of it as not a terrible
description of the president for all the
good and all the ill okay time for a
couple of things that I hate
all righty so today we begin again with
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez got her name
right this time
say alexandria el khazneh Cortez she
said yeah we played her yesterday on
firing line with Margaret Hoover talking
specifically about how she knew nothing
about the Middle Eastern conflicts it
turns out she knows nothing about
economics either here she is explaining
the capitalism is something that didn't
exist in the past and someday won't
exist again and I will explain why she
is both wrong and possibly right
unemployment is low because people are
working 60 70 80 hours a week and can
barely feed their kids and so I do think
that right now when we have this
no-holds-barred wild west hyper
capitalism what that means is profit at
any cost capitalism has not always
existed in the world and it will not
always exist in the world okay she says
that the beginning of that is so
unbelievably stupid it is almost
impossible to describe how stupid it is
when she says she actually said in this
interview that unemployment is low
because people are holding two jobs that
would make unemployment high you idiot
because if one person holds two jobs one
person is out of work presumably so yes
that makes no sense at all thank you for
that also I like how she strings
together all of these buzz words from
Occupy it's hyper capitalist Oh tell me
tell it tell me Alexandra on Assad
Alexandra tell me what is the difference
in capitalist in hyper capitalist I mean
is it like with like the Millennium
Falcon there's like Drive and then
there's hyper drive like you sit there
with Chewie and you pull the lever and
boom zoom you're gone and now you're in
hyper capitalism what the hell is she
even talking about the highest tax rate
in the country
is like over 40 percent people who are
making a lot of money in this country
are paying 45 percent of their income to
the government but we have a hyper
capitalist system here in the United
States that is heavily regulated in
virtually every aspect of the system and
type of capital so that's idiotic
the part she says about capitalism not
always existing and it won't exist in
the future that part is true okay it is
true the capitalism has not always
existed that's why most of the world is
impoverished for most of human history
then we got capitalism and guess what
capitalism is freaking amazing
capitalism raised half the world from
abject poverty since 1980 the number of
people on planet earth living in abject
poverty since 1980 has been sliced in
half hey the reason they
on that Alexandria Acacio Cortez was
able to make a living as a barkeep with
a degree in economics from Boston
University which obviously is worth
nothing right is because she's living in
a capitalist society and she gets to
wear nice dresses and have her special
lipstick that everybody loves capitalism
is the greatest force for human
prosperity ever and is not close Jonah
Goldberg
basically says that capitalism is
artificial because it says you have to
respect other people's property rights
and that centralized planning is not the
way to do things even though there are a
bunch of people who believe they're so
wise they can run the entire economy
from top down it's unnatural for
capitalism to thrive he's correct it is
unnatural for capitalism to thrive when
capitalism dies what you're going to see
is not going to be a return to wonder in
the economy because there was no wonder
in the economy before capitalism
capitalism is free markets they're the
greatest most moral economic system ever
devised by men specifically because they
were not devised by man
they were devised by the idea that you
were supposed to leave each other alone
which I thought was a good thing ok time
to deconstruct the culture so each week
when we when we can we try to go through
a piece of culture that you or your kids
are listening to and we try to
deconstruct what is happening in the
culture because as my good friend Andrew
Breitbart used to say culture is
upstream of politics many more people
and watch this garbage ariana grande
video grande grande video God is a woman
and first before we even play the video
I want to show you how immature ariana
grande is a person not just because she
actually went to a donut shop in Lake
Elsinore California a couple years ago
licked one of the donuts behind the
display case and put it back which is
just gross but because she's a pure
aisle child ok she's a she's not a child
she's a woman she's a woman but she acts
like a child so here's what she tweeted
out somebody tweeted out her god is a
woman tonight so her new song is called
goddess woman will analyze just how
stupid this nonsenses in a second
because God is a woman tonight what's
your favorite word and she tweets back
PU ssy she tweets back the the curse
word for the the vulgarity that
President Trump famously used with
regard to female genitalia if that's her
favorite word I would suggest that you
are an 11 year old I can really if your
favorite word is a is a curse word for a
P for a genital then you are a small
child who's obsessed in an arrested
stage of development it's like how my 2
year olds favorite word right now is
poop because he's - hey
Ariana Grande's favorite if your
favorite word describes your genitals
and it's not just genitals it's your
genitals then I would suggest that you
need some meaning in your life and
that's not all she tweeted she then
tweeted P word is it's a privilege is sa
P word is a privilege not is a P word is
a privilege
so somebody notified general eisah whose
name is spelled exactly the same way the
the House chairman and Government
Oversight yeah let him know the
congressman from California because
apparently P word I saw privilege which
is which is very exciting okay so she
put out she did all this in advance of a
new song that she was put out called God
is a woman now God isn't a woman God
isn't a man God isn't a person my god is
an eternal being who exists beyond space
and time this has been true for every
deist who has ever lived anyone who
believes in in a a one God any theist
believes that God is not a man God is
not a woman God is an eternal being who
is it's beyond space and time and who
designed the universe in which we live
and is the force holding up that
universe right that is the that is the
basic idea of God but because we are now
pagan and we have entered a pagan period
in which everything can be devolved down
to your genitals and how much pleasure
they give you God is apparently a woman
so here is Ariana Grande se grande
Grande a GU singing God is a woman and
she is of course hijacking all the all
the great elements of Western
civilization or to do this so you'll see
at the very end that there's a picture
from the Sistine Chapel in which she has
substituted herself for God reaching out
to Adam in the Sistine Chapel because
this is what we do now what we do is we
take great works of art we take the
history of Western civilization and then
we destroy it on the shoals of our own
hedonism so we have Beyonce and jay-z
talking about ape crap in the Louvre in
front of some of the great sculptures
that were created and then we have
ariana grande hijacking the Sistine
Chapel to talk about her her vagina
which is just it which is just lovely I
mean it really spells I think it's a
good descriptor of where we've gone with
our civilization perhaps when she
realize that this doesn't actually
generate any sort of meaning in her life
that your genitals don't give you
meaning and then anybody who lives by
their genitals will also likely die by
their genitals from an STD
then perhaps we will get a society that
cares about meaning again but here is
ariana grande
making the case for why God is woman
which does if by the way if God is a
woman
why osteoporosis yeah just just
wondering so here here is here's Ariana
Grande warbling got his woman
[Music]
you got
fine
lingas woman you
okay so for those who can't see she's
naked in in paint and then here she is
on a bed with like 73 other people
because this is what God is Right God is
a woman having sex with lots of people
now my favorite part of this is that
Ariana Grande says sex is sex is amazing
because sex gives life right but she's
prone so I'm wondering how that works
and that's and then there's a in this
video a bunch of fat white guys who are
yelling at her so I guess that she will
eventually use this video of me talking
about her to suggest that I don't
appreciate the goddess woman you're
right I don't appreciate God his woman
because that's the stupidest garbage
I've ever heard my life started since
woman goddess into man and God certainly
is not ariana grande an idiotic 22 year
old who can't warble more than octave
that's that's just ridiculous and
boiling down by the way spirituality and
decency and life-giving and the universe
to sex is just it's such a teenage
stupid point of view if your life
revolves around sex you have the
emptiest life you have an empty life sex
is wonderful in the right context sex is
a glorious thing in the right context
but boiling down all of human enjoyments
and meaning in the world to sex makes
you an animal it's not that God is a
woman it's that people are animals okay
in her world this is a better view of
what God is in her world right these
little chipmunks these these ferrets
when is this here groundhogs popping out
and making weird faces at the camera
very very exciting stuff here from
Ariana Grande so what I love is that
this thing has already been viewed tens
of millions of times of course because
the reality is the reality is nobody's
actually gonna imbibe the message okay
the message is is in her clothing right
the message is in the fact that she's
there in body paints I'm old enough to
remember when when people used to
worship at the altar of people like Ella
Fitzgerald
right this is the very closing image is
her with the in the Sistine Chapel
reaching out with surrounded by a bunch
of women of course they it has to be
women of color so that all of the
Rolling Stone folks can say that this is
a recreation of great art but in a more
diverse way very important to do that
it's it's really it's a setting that so
many young people watch the sort of
stuff and think there is some sort of
empowerment or meaning in this if you
find empowerment in this you're fool
this is the least empowering thing if
you are empowered because you have
genitals guess what dogs have genitals
to virtually every living creature has
genitals it's not empowering
genitals it's empowering to use the
stuff between your ears it's empowering
to use your reason it's empowering to
live a life that has actual meaning
beyond sticking your genitals in
particular places and if if God is your
genitals then then God not only does God
not exist you don't exist as a human
being you're just you're just an animal
running around in the dirt okay so I'm
sure she'll use that for her next music
video or if not then then oh well okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire Ford publishing
production copyright Ford publishing